beaucoup de questions beaucoup
d'agitation mais très peu de réponses
dans la nuit de mardi à mercredi le
président haïtien joël moïse a été
assassiné à son domicile
une opération menée par un commando de
28 assaillants 26 colombien et deux
américains d'origine haïtienne dont les
motivations restent pour le moment
inconnues face à cette incompréhension
haïti se tourner vers la colombie ce que
nous voulons en ce moment c'est la
vérité la colombie est très solide en
matière d' enquête c'est un pays bien
préparé dans ce domaine ce que nous
voulons c'est la vérité c'était
tellement locales m à ce stade nous
devons travailler dans l'unité
nous devons coopérer dans l'unité pour
que notre peuple ne souffre pas de ces
actes barbares
nesta abaissiez mena des choses
indécentes c'est de cela qu'il s'agit
mais un des chasses et rate une enquête
c'est que bogota mènent conjointement
avec le gouvernement haïtien
nous avons les premiers détails sur les
voyages que certains d'entre eux ont
fait les dates d'où ils sont partis
quel type de compagnies aériennes ces
informations sont partagées non
seulement avec le bureau central
d'interpol en haïti mais aussi avec la
république dominicaine car les personnes
liées à l'incident ont utilisé comme par
d'arrivée la république dominicaine pour
se rendre en territoire haïtien
l'ascap les personnes capturées nous ont
demandé la nationalité colombienne et
sur caliendo nationale et à columbia et
bord deux personnes sont mortes lors de
la procédure policière en haïti
pour lui si d'après bogota 17 des 26
colombiens ont appartenu à l'armée
nationale
parmi ces suspects onze ont été arrêtés
ce vendredi dont le complexe de
l'ambassade de taïwan à port au prince
mais l' enquête semble loin d'être
terminée dans un pays en proie à
l'instabilité et pour éviter que des
infrastructures vitales soit visé pour
créer la confusion
les autorités haïtiennes ont demandé
l'envoi de troupes armées de l'onu et
des états unis
les etats unis restent engagés en
consultation étroite avec nos
partenaires haïtiens et internationaux
pour soutenir le peuple haïtien
en réponse à la demande d'assistance en
matière de sécurité et d'enquêté
formulée par le gouvernement haïtien
nous allons envoyer des responsables du
fbi à et de la sécurité intérieure à
port-au-prince aussi vite que possible
pour évaluer la situation et déterminer
comment nous pouvons apporter notre aide
entre après l'assassinât de son
président en haïti avait plongé dans le
chaos durant plusieurs jours mais depuis
ce vendredi
la tension semble redescendu à port au
prince pourtant l'incompréhension reste
encore palpable et les suspicions
grandissent autour de la police chargée
de la sécurité du président certains
hauts responsables ont été convoqués
devant la justice pour savoir comment
dans cet assaut meurtrier de jouvenel
moïse aucun policier n'a été tué